and if instead you want to go for the
classic big game treat i have the
perfect place for you and it's all
thanks to
brooklyn's best
for the big game special we're offering
a large cheese pizza
and any kind of wing they want for the
big game
you get a big pizza like this it's huge
we're going to cut into eight slices for
you guys
and we don't mess around you're not
going to get no cheap pizza we use
grande mozzarella
san marzano tomato you're going to get
the best pizza you ever had
don't mess around don't go to these guys
over here new york style
come get new york they have cheese pizza
pepperoni pizza
sausage pizza supreme pizza meat lovers
pizza sicilian style
grandma style stuffed pizza any kind of
pizza you want we got it right here
well you should celebrate with us
because we're the original and the only
ones that are truly from new york from
brooklyn and we do it the right way
straight out of the oven bam does not
flop
no flapping no flopping here
right way is it the boss is here i'm
making the pies i'm making the dough i'm
doing the sauce for my guys
there's no one else making it it's not
frozen it's made here fresh every single
day
we just won uh a trifecta in the best of
las vegas
we won gold for best family restaurant
best casual restaurant silver for pizza
silver for best italian
and bronze for the wings the wings are
bomb we're not even a wings place
but we just renovated we got some new
hot boxes here
we just added some gelato we added
another pizza oven because we're so busy
uh we added another
slice display over here all new
refrigeration
our ranges are new we added a salamander
a lot of a lot of new equipment uh our
dining room's a little bit smaller due
to covert but
it's working right now a lot of people
are staying up later now
the work schedules are changing we're
now staying open at 2 am
every thursday friday and saturday
nights you know come see me i'll be here
we'll be selling slices all night long
the the menu never changes
and then also we got a nice mural coming
up all your favorite uh
brooklyn characters from biggie smalls
jay-z
j-lo they're all beyond the wall come
see them oh celebrate with us by giving
us a call
or sending it in uh via online
ordering or just come in uh but try to
order your stuff ahead of time because
we're gonna be real busy so you can get
that big game special
for just 27.95 that's a large cheese
and any wing any style
[Music]
right there that's brooklyn's best pizza
and pasta to get the game day special
it's 27 95 for large cheese pizza
and 10-piece chicken wing so just call
702-786-0103 or visit
brooklynbestpizzanpasta.com we'll be
right back